Most people don't know or don't care who you are.
Sometimes, if I tell somebody who I am, they'll say, "No, you ain't."
The hardest thing to be in songwriting is to be simple and yet profound.
Bill seemed to understand how to do that.
Most of the major record companies call me up.
They had this rhythm and blues syndrome in their minds, with the horns and the three chicks...
...and the gold lame suit.
And I wasn't really into that.
So I thought, "Well, I got this good job making these toilets. I don't need you guys."
My real life was when I was just a working guy.
You know, it's okay to...
...head out for wonderful.
But on your way to wonderful, you gonna have to pass through alright.
And when you get to alright, take a good look around and get used to it,...
...'cause that may be as far as you gonna go.
There are millions and millions of people that would love to see and hear Bill Withers again.
I want everybody to look at me and everybody to wanna know me, and...
...there was a time when that was... that was it, huh?
Bill Withers can work a whole lot and make a whole lot of money if he wanted to do that.
I'm trying to give myself a chance to get driven.
Thoreau I think said, "The mass of men lead lives of quiet desperation."
I would like to know how it feels for my desperation to get louder.
Both personally...
...as a human being and as a great artist that you are,...
...what would you want your legacy to be?